hey guys it is Monday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan and I got a bunch of things to
talk about today so without further ado
here's gamespot news first up called GD
World War 2 is out now but multiplayer
issues have been plaguing the game since
lon I certainly have developer
sledgehammer games are starting to roll
out some fixes that are starting to have
the intended effects after an update
released last week had an adverse effect
on server performance sledgehammer moved
from dedicated service to a p2p setup a
p2p connection bypasses the dedicated
middle machine and connects players to
one another this can result in annoying
things like host migration but
sledgehammer pledged that they would be
bringing the dedicated servers back up
in due time they're currently testing
dedicated service on ps4 in the US with
promising results and the test will soon
be rolled out to those of you on Xbox
one
a patch is also rolling out to fix the
disconnection issues a lot of players
are experiencing and should hit sometime
in the next day or so if it hasn't since
shooting unfortunately the game's new
social space headquarters will remain a
solo experience for the foreseeable
future
not long after launch sledgehammer
changed headquarters to a solo space to
help with online performance pledging to
bring it back up once the pressing
concerns were addressed in the meantime
you can invite your buds to come hang
out and do the hubba-hubba shoulder wipe
on the beaches of Normandy your games a
weird I've seen with my own papers to PU
in pub G Wow
and it seems like the old PU has been
pretty busy as a new update
battlegrounds is being pushed to the
test service tonight also we have
vaulting suite the test build will be
live from November 13th at 6 p.m. until
November 14th at 6 p.m. PST apart from
the very welcome addition of vaulting
Irvan e hi wolves this also changes to
ballistics to help make the game more
balanced and realistic in a post on the
game's steam community page developer
blue hole has outlined the changes that
are incoming bullets will now be
affected by air resistance and will drop
much further over long distances red dot
and holographic sights can now have the
intensity of their sights adjusted and
damage to limbs has been changed so that
it now more accurately reflects where a
player has been hit also next will now
be predicted by helmets so that's pretty
sweet cheaters also get a look-in in the
latest post with blue hull saying that
their current efforts have seen overall
cheating
being reduced by 25% and the volume of
malicious extreme cheaters has reduced
by 50% if you want to give in your test
builder bash just keep in mind you might
see some client crashes player unknowns
battlegrounds is out on PC in early
access and we'll hit Xbox one on
December 12th for 30 bucks things have
gone from bad to somehow even more bad
for EA winner of worst company in
America between 2012 and 2013 in an
attempt to soothe the concerns over
battlefront twos loot boxes they jumped
into the reddit comment section backlash
reignited over the weekend as gamers
realized they couldn't access certain
hero characters including Darth Vader
after purchasing the game as they are
locked and attempting to unlock them
would allegedly take 40 hours of game
time each given the price of characters
was 60 thousand credits while the rate
of earning credits was slow in
comparison EA cropped up in a thread
regarding these concerns on reddit where
the company explained the intent is to
provide players with a sense of pride
and accomplishment for unlocking
different heroes as the cost we selected
initial values based upon data from the
open beta and other adjustments made to
milestone rewards before launch among
other things we're looking at average
per player credit earn rates on a daily
basis and we'll be making constant
adjustments to ensure that players have
challenges that are compelling rewarding
and of course attainable via gameplay
long story short EA now has the most
downvoted comment of all time on reddit
Goodwin EA another thing that has been
sticking in the crawler of fans is that
there has been a price hike in
microtransactions since the beta EA said
beta prices were lowered to allow
players to experience all the beta had
to offer we should note that as of
earlier today EA released a statement
saying that they are reducing the amount
of credits needed to unlock the top
heroes by 75% so Luke Skywalker and
Vader will now cost fifteen thousand
credits instead of sixty thousand the
other heroes are also significantly
cheaper this change is going live in an
update today the statement explained
based on what we've seen in the trial
this amount will make earning these
heroes an achievement but one that will
be accessible for all players and what
is a fairly ballsy move that I will
definitely be tuning in for the
publisher are hosting a reddit AMA this
Wednesday so if you want to see how that
all goes down don't miss it that's
everything we have for you today enjoy
the rest of your day and we'll be here
all week and then we'll also be here on
the weekend because it's GameSpot extra
life this weekend
starting on Friday in the u.s. at 12
p.m. PST and then running 72 hours all
the way through will be on at 12 p.m. at
PST on Saturday yeah PST time which is 7
a.m. Sunday our time and will be on for
24 hours and then you'll it'll be
rounded out by the UK this year but I
please tune in donate it's for the kids
and enjoy us losing our minds very
slowly we'll see you then and tomorrow
you're a large man poking this
electricity